les clients se succèdent dans le bureau
de cette exterminateur ce matin ils sont
une trentaine à avoir tous le même
problème des punaises de lit dites vous
qu en 2000 je faisais à peu près 1 ou 2
go de punaises par année dans le moment
j'ai enfin de 50 et saint fargeau
les punaises ne se retrouvent plus
uniquement dans les logements ou les
hôtels
aujourd'hui même j'ai des interventions
dans des hôpitaux dans des bibliothèques
à des salles d'essayage
enfin taxi a trop tard on pensait la
grande bibliothèque on a retrouvé la
semaine dernière sans jamais être
infesté elle reçoit une dizaine de
signalements chaque année à l'échelle de
tout le québec plus d'un millier
d'exterminateurs certifié se partagent
le travail et j'en connais plus j'ai
acquis sont obligées d'augmenter leurs
personnels même de vraies d'autres
kursaal été le phénomène des problèmes
la problématique des punaises deux
niveaux en croissant nous on voit de
plus en plus de problèmes que même des
exterminateurs qui ont abandonné toutes
les autres sphères d'activités qui ne
font que ça que de la punaise de lit
les propriétaires sont vraiment de plus
en plus décourager pourtant la ville de
montréal affirme chiffres à l'appui que
la situation est stable mais pour 2015
ces données s'arrête au mois de mai
avant la période des déménagements
la ville ne tient pas compte non plus de
la résistance qu'ont développé les
punaises dans certains écueils 4,5
visiter on y soit réglé le problème
la dernière limite des chiffres
officiels c'est qu'ils tiennent
seulement compte des interventions dans
les logements mais pas ailleurs
comme le confirme cette responsable de
la salubrité son internet sur la
distance est une prérogative minispace
je parle pas des internes en cendres des
garderies au niveau des écoles au niveau
des hôpitaux au niveau des hôtels au
niveau des bibliothèques etc
l'administration coderre reconnaît qu'il
serait souhaitable que tous les lieux où
se trouve la punaise soient
comptabilisés c'est pourquoi elle
demande à québec de prendre en compte
les institutions qui sont sous sa
responsabilité
parce que pendant ce temps la punaise
progresse elle ne connaît pas les
frontières des juridictions ici thomas
gerber radio canada montréal